make you fancy alvin oh no we're making
it big that's the name of this show
this is a 100 egg omelets
[Music]
it's a damn lot of eggs it's a lot of
time shout out to all my hens out there
you're the real ones all right stay
together stay together one two three
open your eyes really
what's up guys i'm alvin i love making
giant food and today on tasty's making
it big we're gonna do some crazy stuff
today i'll be cooking for my fellow
tasty producer rea you might have seen
her on worth it on eating her feed and a
lot of other tasty videos she's an
amazing producer and a wonderful chef i
want to see if i can make something
that's really cool that'll really
impress her so let's go see what she
wants to eat today hello hey helping
how's it going good did you have any
lunch or dinner plans today i didn't
have lunch i didn't have breakfast even
so i'm very hungry what do you
personally enjoy like eating on a
day-to-day basis i love japanese
breakfast okay rice miso soup and
tamagoyaki which is japanese style
omelette the one where they like cook it
in the pan it rolls up exactly okay so i
would be so impressed if you made me
omelette like a giant omelette giant
omelet oh
well just to be clear though like
american omelets and japanese almonds
are different right like what makes them
so unique so japanese omelette it's like
you explain it's like rolled and it's
layered america omelette has a lot of
fun ingredients like peppers caramelized
onions bacon and cheese are those you're
like your favorite ingredients in
omelets yeah i love caramelized onion
and a bacon combination doesn't seem
like it's going to be very easy make you
fancy alvin oh no we're making it big
that's the name of the show oh i have an
idea yeah not only i'm going to make you
a giant omelette what if i make you a
100 egg omelet 100 egg omelette 100 egg
omelette it would be so amazing
okay yeah okay i'm gonna get to it
okay here we are as you can see i have
many many many eggs i've never purchased
handled or seen this many eggs in one
place in my entire life so the first
step to making a 100 egg omelet is to
crack 100 eggs so let's get cracking
oh i broke the first one we are off to a
fantastic start
to crack eggs you want to take the egg
and you want to crack it on a flat
surface not on the edge of a pan or a
bowl because it could really shatter the
inside
knock knock who's there you know just an
egg
sometimes people ask me
what came first chicken
or the egg
after hours of deliberation
i don't really know
fun fact a hen lays one egg every 26
hours so that means for one hen to lay
100 eggs
that would
that would be
ah damn i'm asian i should be knowing
this better days 108 days and eight
hours for one hen to lay 100 eggs also
known as a damn long time
shout out to all my hands out there
you're the real ones
we're almost there it's been quite a
journey number 100
[Music]
okay we have
officially cracked 100 eggs into this
bowl it's a damn lot of eggs it's a lot
of time thank you chickens for your hard
work see you in a bit
so these are 100 eggs we're just going
to whisk them and i'm going to season
them later i'm actually very excited for
this we're going to go
[Music]
there's so many eggs i can't even get
them all
i want to make sure this is the
smoothest egg mixture anybody's ever
seen so i want to whisk the crap out of
these eggs
it's a workout
right arm's getting real tired about now
oh there was one yoga i missed there you
go i got you that's right you don't
escape from me
i eat yolks for breakfast
actually though
i like this beet
[Music]
that's the egg beat
all right i'm done
arm's dying
i'm so tired
i'm slowing down it's not a vortex
anymore
it's a kidding pool
i want to say that's pretty much done
you know we got a nice consistent color
we're all good we're going to add some
salt i don't know how much salt to put
in because it's 100 eggs so i kind of
eyeball it
i won't say that's enough i'm going to
transfer these and start rolling our
omelette my technique for making this
omelette is similar to the japanese
style which is called a tamagoyaki i
think it's going to be like a rolled
omelette so what i'm going to do is we
have two of these trays lined with
silpat to make sure it doesn't stick i'm
actually just going to brush this with a
lot of butter butter and eggs you know
fantastic marriage obviously you know we
could dump 100 eggs you know into a pan
maybe but it's kind of boring you know
it's not what i do i have no idea if
this is going to stay upright if it's
going to break but it's all good we're
going to
basically try to pour some eggs in here
i'm going to guess like a quart of eggs
per container
mmm delicious
oh yes nothing like pouring liquid eggs
let's go evenly it's enough eggs i hope
it's enough eggs i think it's enough
eggs nice nice nice all right let's go
for round two
all right i'm gonna go and take these to
the oven to bake i want it to set into a
nice sheet but i don't want it to
overcook we're gonna cook at 300 for i'm
going to say 10 minutes i'm gonna very
carefully take this to the oven all
right alvin don't you mess this up now
your honor is on the line cannot
displease rye
okay we have nice uh big egg sheets here
this was a little lopsided i think in
the oven just kind of tips a little bit
that way it's okay i'm gonna put some
cheese on it and i wash my hands so
we're all clean this is gonna go like
over here yeah here we go
the heat from the egg sheets are going
to actually help melt the cheese while
it's being rolled we're gonna do some
bacon bits on here i love bacon really
likes bacon and this is gonna be fun
that's kind of awesome and we're just
gonna kind of go for it and roll it and
see if this works so first you gotta get
it to go around though keep it all tight
yeah there we go
all right
so sheet number one we're gonna transfer
it over to here we're gonna do the same
thing
coming out
and landing
it's going well so far no major hiccups
we're gonna keep going
okay
and there you have it
that's roll number two edges looking a
little floppy that's okay i'm gonna need
to reuse these trays though so we're
gonna transfer this onto a board
this is getting heavy already
to keep this warm i'm gonna cover it in
some foil
and then
we're gonna do
two more trays
each one of these i think is around 20
eggs hopefully
i didn't miss measure
train number three train number four 20
eggs a piece let's put them back in the
oven fingers crossed i can keep rolling
this without it breaking or doing
anything because surprisingly this is
going according to plan
all right these look pretty fantastic
fix the little oven adjustments so a
little bit smoother we got some nice
american cheese look at this
beautiful
stack it's like i got the cheddar like
in the rap music videos
load this guy up
actually very fun
i'm a happy boy
not too much
some for me
this is it for this one that one's gonna
get ham
it's like i'm painting but with food i
think it's time to roll we're gonna take
the one we made before and then somehow
get this onto here
all right well we've landed now we're
gonna start to roll again
like that
now it's getting kind of heavy tuck it
tuck it okay oh smooth then one more
time
all right okay
it's getting kind of crazy
uh but you know we're all good
keep together relatively well and now we
have to get that guy onto here
am i strong enough to do this
on
all right
[Music]
successful landing
this omelette is one big bull
all right and then one more time
oh the tray is tipping
okay so uh we are currently at 80 eggs
this is getting heavy
the omelet is on the board
still got a little bit to go
i'm gonna set this aside and we're gonna
go for the last 20 eggs oh my god this
is heavy oh
okay so
i think i might have miscalculated how
many eggs i need to use per tray this
won't make
enough for two trays this is only gonna
be enough for like one and a half so
we're going big i think let's do 120
eggs i'm gonna whisk this one more time
to make sure we're okay
i don't know if you guys have seen the
100 layer lasagna video i ended up doing
104 layers on accident it's kind of in
my blood to
go a little bit over what i'm used to
doing i'm trying to impress rye
hopefully she will be impressed by the
fact that i went above and beyond for
her this is a hundred eggs
[Music]
oh a yolk filled out that's okay
we're gonna whisk it back in
120 eggs the final layer might be a
little heftier than most because it
needs to be the outer layer
i'm going to take this in to bake and
we're going to hope that we can actually
make this work because if it's too big
and it breaks i'm going to be very sad
don't film me now
oh
so this is the fifth sheet 100 eggs
this is the sixth one 120. i think they
look beautiful i think they look super
smooth rye loves caramelized onions so
we have caramelized onions i also do
want to put a little bit more cheese
because i think it'll help bind the last
layer i think it's going to taste
pretty darn awesome there's a lot of
flavors going on it's got sweetness you
got creaminess you got saltiness pretty
much and every single layer been a long
journey i've used probably
like
five pounds of cheese at this point i
think it's gonna be pretty awesome
so we got a really heavy guy
over here we're gonna start rolling and
hopefully that everything goes according
to plan
oh that was really heavy oh my god this
guy's getting massive oh this might be
tough this is heavy i gotta grip it
right 100 this little extra legroom is
gonna help we're gonna move it on to
120. it all comes down to this folks i
don't know if you can tell
this is wobbling
i need this guy to last me one more and
then we'll be okay please
don't fail me now come up
okay
okay
the reason i put this guy in the middle
because i want to fold this over and
then just do one last roll and we'll be
there this is the big moment
last layer
all right that is on
all right stay together stay together
stay together stay together
all right
we did it
this is a
120 egg omelets it's very big it is very
heavy while it's still warm i do want to
serve it but i also need to decorate it
a little bit so to finish really likes
chives and ketchup on her omelets i'm
going to draw a face and hopefully it
looks kind of cool
okay so now i gotta give this guy cheeks
[Music]
this is my uh attempt to add a design
not the next picasso but that's okay i'm
gonna finish this with a touch of chives
just in the front and in the back
okay those are the last of the chives uh
it's been crazy this is one heavy guy so
we're gonna go get this omelette to
really
hey area yeah you ready for your
omelette i'm ready all right close your
eyes please okay i'm very excited to see
what you think on the count of three one
two three open your eyes
it's really cute
oh my god
i thought you're gonna make just a
american omelette this is japanese one
it's an old one oh my god it's actually
not a hundred eggs uh-huh it's 120
because i was like you know what i'm
just gonna go we could do one more i
love it
you want me to cut it open for you yes
if you want to give it a name before we
cut it in half you're more than welcome
to well let's name this um after your
middle name which is carl whiskey why
did you have to tell them
the tables have turned
sorry carl
no it was carl oh
whoa
look at the layer
this is what it looks like on the inside
you're touching carl
how does carl feel
power it's very bouncy did carl give you
permission
here is your omelette thank you
i like your mouth
wow
tasty look colorful too so it sounds
like carl was a success how was success
you impressed me
i'm happy i finally got the chance to
cook for you thank you so much yeah
anytime
please continue to eat okay
i think
rest of the world should see this okay
[Music]
well we did it guys we impressed rye a
lot of effort but i think it definitely
was worth it i think now i have a
newfound respect for eggs and this is it
this is the final episode and this
season's tasty is making it big it's
been a blast six episodes six crazy
giant dishes for six amazing people i'm
super happy that i got the chance to do
this i'm always going to be trying to do
bigger and better things so until next
time
peace
[Music]
you